[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day today
we're talking about the Oscars they just
announced they're making three changes
they're gonna make a shorter ceremony
they're moving up the ceremony to
February and they're adding a whole new
category called outstanding achievement
and popular film they're trying to make
it less elitist but Jordan you hear this
everyone's upset about it because
everyone gets upset about anything you
[Laughter]
do we like that they added this category
I mean it's just so elitist it's just so
embarrassing
III mean I'm excited to see you know who
wins but it's just yeah I wouldn't want
to win that if I made a movie I would
not want to win that award I'd want to
win Best Picture I wouldn't want to win
like well you made something that idiots
like but they should just celebrate the
best movie like The Dark Knight was the
best movie that year us was the best
movie and they put them in these little
categories the Dark Knight didn't win
Best Picture even though it was the best
they're like oh you can't have a good
script about Batman but it has to be
another movie about the Queen of England
they're both rich people they added five
more five more nominees so now there's
ten nominees for Best Picture instead of
five because of the yeah but to do this
popularity contest
category or whatever that is it's like
The Dark Knight was the best script the
best movie that year not every superhero
movie needs to be acknowledged now we're
always going to acknowledge one or
probably because that's likely what's
going to be the most popular thing or
the do or the ROC's
movies that you watch on flights or
going we do all of the rap I'm into it
you like it I think it's great yeah I
think it's the more opportunity for like
more movies to win the better this was
like in high school in my high school we
gave out tons of super lives in a way
that was like I think everyone got one
Daytime Emmys there's any one I agree
with Natasha is anyone else excited
about I'm
whatever it's like I'd more I'd rather
see that than sound mixing I
we're sorry Josh you know but I agree
there's an award for best sound mixing
and an award for best sound editing your
step just wowed it's like transformer as
always what can I just say this is I've
never heard Nate like sake okay I'm
gonna unleash my wrath so elitist man
with how audiences literally die and why
should they ad then what should they add
next best Lifetime Achievement Award
winner make them compete and some kind
of like double dare I like that I think
it should be a category for like best
movie to like eat food during the best
one to see at the Alamo I went to see
like spotlight and I got food and I was
like this is bad yeah I can't be eating
during this movie I mean I think it was
like chips or something but it's like
that's not why it's not like it's like
it's a quiet no I totally get she's
gonna chill you might not hear it if
you're doing the chili without a snack I
always have popcorn I would say infinity
war was a great movie I eat a whole
flatbread I was like well Alamo has it
on the menu I'm gonna eat it okay they
just have it on the menu as a trick to
see who's in consider
George gets a guacamole maybe chef's
were the guys he stands in front of you
and like he's just throwing shrimp at
you or like this category was made for
Black Panther right so they're they're
the Oscars aren't saying that but that's
what a lot of people are suspecting
which if that is the case I think we'll
they'll get more for that than not I
think it does if they relegated to that
category instead of giving it Best
Picture
but it wasn't the best picture I think
it is very good I feel like this is like
blasphemy like the liberal media elite
well like guilty me for saying this but
like it was a really good movie a really
good movie but there were some holes and
I think out of the Avengers that Xfinity
world was better no but I love but the
problem here is just like instead of
trying to make a new lit category just
just things accurately stop playing
favorites that's all that's the problem
it's like you feel bad because you've
been neglecting so many years of good
cinema some being black some being other
races Asian communities been neglected
for a long time also and now they just
feel bad that we want to just make it so
we don't have to save the movies good we
could say the people said it was good
and I can just still say you think it's
like oh right you think they was like
maybe unintentionally or intentionally
like racist or racially motivated to
make the category yes if you see
Hollywood it's awful place full of all
the people who touch people in a row
my man is good movie I love all of them
but I think it's what else how do you
define best what was the most fun what
pushed the boundaries of cinema you
haven't seen any of them do you want to
I can choose what movies I want to watch
[Laughter]
Jordan you ever apply we actually we
have a new category on our show which is
a best outstanding achievement in the
comments-section
grass I think you have the winter photo
one of my favorite sketches is from
Chappelle's Show when Bill burr played
detective on the Law & Order episode do
me a favor and not smoke I'm allergic
oh hey I'm sorry Chuck when I do you a
favor and put it out there for you huh
you made a post about that and one of
the comments was yellow cake from Africa
don't drop that I got a yellow cake
right here look she leaves
don't drop bad thanks for leaving the
comment we're gonna do something else
right now so you know there's a lot of
like hate in the world and I think that
just in general we should love each
other more so I made you guys some
cupcakes so what this is a Giada De
Laurentiis recipe I got from Food
Network so I figured we'd eat these
cupcakes and just just just talk no
these are give me one did you drink
come on man it does I am nervous yeah I
don't eat it no you're actually so funny
you should eat a cupcake
and the cupcake alright I'll grab only
one good it's great great good job
was it hard to make it took me like five
hours for real why it took me forever
yeah just because I messed up the first
batch I think it's great
oh my girlfriend ice them because I was
tired even by his okay I want to share
it so I'm a little bit okay Hannah
swallowed oh yeah I forgot
there's a really good copy I'm happy to
work with you Jordan so do you remember
do you remember a few days ago when you
guys pranked me when you said yeah we
all have this trip to go to Los Angeles
and you said oh you convinced me that I
wasn't going you all were in on it I
know it I know it and now I got you back
Aynsley can you play the clip
[Music]
I don't think I can handle this your
girlfriend she's recording this well you
know thank you for being idiots I
basically had sex with these cupcakes so
enjoy it
[Music]
yeah The Shining is about a man that
kills his entire family but isn't it
really a story about how hard it is to
write books
[Music]
I'm not apologizing I earlier in today's
episode I said some unfortunate things
to sound mixers sound designers and
sound editors and I for one would like
to apologize I'm sorry I'm sorry see you
next time on everyday
[Music]